b vous dites non pourquoi je sens que je
vais t'énerver pas du tout non non mais
c'est pas la peine de parler de conseil
constitutionnel non je veux pas parler
du Conseil constitutionnel moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'efficacité des
mesures le problème des fichiers c'est
qu'ils sont pas ils sont pas
judiciarisés donc c'est impossible à
faire donc en revanche moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'efficacité des
mesures avec deux solutions la première
ce serait de créer des vrais centres de
déradicalisation je l'ai déjà dit ici et
la deuxième c'est que moi
personnellement je suis tout à fait pour
un une prison à la Guantanamo parce que
le problème c'est que bah oui parce que
là le problème c'est que les fichers
vous allez vous baser sur quoi pour
pouvoir aller les
interpeller parce que tu met
nonux pris
gue un centre de rétion on déjà eximé
sur ce point j'ai déjà dit que j'étais
pour des centres de déradicalisation y
compris pour les enfants on a déjà eu ce
débat donc sur le fond je suis d'accord
simplement là ça n'est pas
possibleov fa tu March à la tu prais35
ball tu mais pas ton
tuis5 les mesur les on
48ème ça a divisé par 10 le nombre
d'attentats P où ça a été fait c'est ce
qu'on vient de me dire vous pourrez
vérifier dans un du Nord je
crois je vous le dis ça a été divisé par
10 donc existe en Israël ouais aussi
c'est un pays qui est victime
régulièrement d'attentat terrorist mais
nous en sommes là aujourd'hui on d'une
certaine manière on peut se comparer à
des pays aujourd'hui qui vivent sous la
menace islamiste et terroriste
permanente est-ce que c'est justement
vous allez proposer cette loi mais vous
y croyez ou pas du tout bah ce qui me
rend un peu optimiste c'est que j'ai vu
qu'un certain nombre de personnes
commencer à l'évoquer voilà ou tourner
autour sans jamais aller jusqu'au bout
j'ai vu que Manuel Vals en avait parlé
d'ailleurs Nicolas Sarkozy en avait
parlé en son temps j'ai vu que Gérald
Darmanin a dit qu'il é à toutes sortes
de proposition Gérard Darmanin il est
ouvert à toutes sortes de propositions
mais c'est pas Gérard daranin c'est mais
le problème non mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que on a aussi un
certain nombre de personnes qui ne
veulent pas se poser les questions de
l'origine aussi de cette situation
c'est-à-dire que à un moment donné il
faut quand même regarder en face que le
terrro islamiste dans notre pays se
développe sur le communautarisme
islamique se développe sur une
immigration incontrôlée euh et
désassimilée ou inassimilé qui du coup
devient un vivier de recrutement
favorable et que si à un moment donné
vous n'êtes pas capable de regarder ça
en face et d'apporter aussi des
solutions en amont vous ne faites
qu'alimenter un flux et qu'alimenter la
la gravité je rappelle que ce
gouvernement a également rapatrié des
dizaines d'islamistes de Syrie donc
grossissant ainsi quand même le flux de
de la menace donc c'est vrai que j'ai
j'ai une confiance relative voilà
question est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
vous avez le le vous vous rendez compte
aussi parfois Marion maréchal qui a des
des musulmans qui quand il voit toutes
ces attaques toutes ces attaques
terroristes se sentent encore plus
blessés dégoûté que euh et quel ambigué
j'ai truc moi j'ai pas d'ambigé non mais
non est-ce que vous rendez compte que
parfois il y a un amalgame qui est fait
et qui fait énormément de mal aussi à à
la communauté musulmane et qui se
sentent parfois même eux ici en France
en France il se sentent ils se sentent
qui dans qui dans le qui aujourd'hui
dans le discours public dit tous les
musulmans sont des
terroristes si il y en a qui honnêtement
non
personne a des voilà on entend des
choses parfois qui sont parfois limit et
qui font que des gens voilà
qui compliqué c'est compliqué parce que
évidemment aujourd'hui tous les
musulmans et Français de confession
musulman ne sont pas des terroristes
c'est une absolue évidence c'est R pourx
et tous les terroristes sont des
musulmans radicalisés donc c'est vrai
que du coup aujourd'hui le fait de
dénoncer l'islamisme fait que parfois je
sais pas on se fait reprocher une forme
de racisme ou d'amalgame religieux mais
c'est pas le cas et d'ailleurs je pense
sont des Français de confession
musulmanes attaché à leur à le à leur
sécurité à la sécurité de leurs enfants
et qui veulent éviter justement bascule
dans l'islamisme ils ont plutôt intérêt
eux aussi à regarder les choses en face
et à appeler des solutions radicales
parce que ils en sont en tout cas les
les premiers exposés le famille trois
dernière petites questions vous me
répondez juste en une phrase les J va
bien se passer on est prêt ou on n'est
pas prêt je sais pas quand j'ai vu
comment s'est passé le stade de France
j'ai j'ai quelques inquiétudes quoi il
paraî que c'était les supporters anglais
qui m' regardé ouai c'est ça donc je
sais pas peut-être que les surporurs
Anglais vont recommencer euh la mort de
Thomas on en parle encore dans son
village de wadrome une récupération
politique ou pas on n'en parle plus et
surtout on ne parle plus pour moi de ce
qui est quand même l'un des sujets
centraux c'est-à-dire
l'expression violente d'un racisme
antiblanc le procureur ur de la
République n'a même pas daigné retenir
dans les motifs c'està dire il n'a pas
retenu la circonstance aggravante du
racisme alors que ça a été demandé par
la famille il n'a même pas retenu
l'injure raciale alors queon a des
racilles qui ont dit on est là pour
planter du blanc on est là pour tuer du
blanc d'après neuf témoins moi tout ce
que je constate c'est que il y a une
indignation à deux vitesses en ce qui
concerne ce sujet je pense que si ça
avait été Thomas et ses petits copains
qui étaient descendu à roman suriser en
disant on va planter de l'arabe ou tuer
de l'arabe je pense que la réaction
politique la réaction médiatique et la
réaction judiciaire légitimement
d'ailleurs n'aurait pas été la même la
journalisteutel keV placé sous
protection policière après un tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-il IR
respponsable Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour
vous oui il est responsable il est
irresonsable parce que en fait
aujourd'hui il est dans une espèce de
fuite en avant de calcul
électoraliste d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que en fait il espère
je pense à travers ses positions sur
Gaza et et et sur Israël surfer sur une
forme de communautarisme islamiste dans
le pays il se dit que pour des raisons
démographiques euh bah ça lui servira
dans les années à venir mais c'est
évidemment extrêmement dangereux pour la
cohésion nationale extrêmement dangereux
pour pour le le la la bonne entente on
va dire dans notre pays et puis ça
expose des gens comme adame routel crief
qui aujourd'hui ont des cibles dans le
dos parce queil faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays on peut
avoir des fatis très facilement avoir
des cibles dans le dos donc c'est vrai
que c'est c'est cet homme est de plus en
plus terrifiant il est dangereux
Jean-Luc mélcheux Mélenchon il est
dangereux vraiment ah bah il est il est
il est oui il est dangereux en ce sens
que pour moi c'est un homme qu'on dit
moi c'est marrant parce que je je fais
partie de celles qui en permanence se
prennent dans la tête le fait qu'elles
veulent fracturer
diviser opposer moi au contraire je je
j'essaie de faire en sorte que ces
oppositions et ce fractures se réduisent
parce que je les vois arriver je les
vois grandir Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il
les utilise Il sf dessus il les a
parfaitement intégré et il est en train
de dresser une partie de la France issue
de
l'immigration et musulmane justement
contre le peuple historique à travers ce
sujet et je trouve que c'est je trouve
que c'est
dangereux et terrifiant dernière petite
question est-ce que c'est pas une chance
pour vous Jean-Luc Mélenchon non c'est
pas une chance d'avoir aujourd'hui un
responsable politique qui est aussi haut
vie publque ou mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le parti qui
fait le plus peur aujourd'hui on le voit
dans les sondages le parti qui fait le
plus peur c'est la LFI avant c'était oui
mais moi je fais pas ce genre de calcul
je fais je vais pas je vais pas me
féliciter aujourd'hui que il y ait un
homme qui aujourd'hui demain et qume
candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et puisse aboutir à ce à
quoi il aboutit moi don j'ai env c'est
que je sais que vous aimez la France
mais restez quand même une femme
politique je suis désolé moi quand pad
il y a un forfait d'un mec très fort je
suis très content he euh non mais c'est
vrai ou ou pas moi quand au forfait
demifinale un mec il est très fort il
est forfait il s'est blessé je suis très
content je lui dis voilà mais bon voilà
mais ce qui me plairait davantage c'est
plutôt que les Français entendent
l'exactitude du propos que je tiens et
et et la réalité du diagnostic et voilà
éventuellement l'originalité et sérieux
des propositions c'est pas par effet
miroir interposer parce que Jean-Luc
Mélanchon serait plus méchant que
j'apparaîtrai plus gentil enfin très
bien mais enfin c'est pas très solide
quand même comme comme avantage merci
Marion Marichal avec nous tout de suite
magéon sur C8 merci